Florrie Lachlan and her husband Massimo
Jian Uli are getting ready to pack their
moving trucks et have learned that the
couple's bel-air mansion is currently in
escrow and has past contingencies et
previously reported that the couple
listed their spanish-style residents in
January with a price tag of twenty-eight
million six hundred and fifty thousand
dollars our source says they've since
entertained multiple offers and while
they aren't getting the original asking
price according to our source the former
actress and her husband are still making
a profit on the sale and are quote happy
with the deal I'll be sending you the
listing agreement right now the agency's
Arvin Haddad is handling the listing ét
previously reported that everyone seemed
shocked by Lori and Massimo's decision
to put their home on the market but a
source told et at the time that the
couple is wanted to sell for a while
adding that it just hasn't been a
priority with everything we've been
going through in the past year according
to our source listing their home has
helped Florian Massimo feel like they're
taking a step towards getting their
lives quote back to normal I don't feel
like we're that like interesting or
entertaining like we're just a nice
normal family you know like we don't we
don't have anything outrageous really
happening nearly two months ago Lachlan
and Jian Yu Lee pleaded guilty for their
role in the College Admission scandal
the two were accused of paying five
hundred thousand dollars in bribes to
get their daughters Olivia Jade and
Isabella Rose admitted to USC as
recruits on the crew team even though
neither daughter had ever participated
in the sport
the couple initially pleaded not guilty
to all charges claiming their payments
were donations to the school rather than
bribes I just want them to have that
experience and get that education and
have a degree to fall back on in her
plea deal Lachlan agreed to serve two
months in prison and two years of
supervised release plus pay a fine of
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars
the 55 year old also agreed to complete
100 hours of community service meanwhile
her husband's dealing
clewd serving a five month prison
sentence with two years of supervised
release a two hundred and fifty thousand
dollar fine and two hundred and fifty
hours of community service
the couple's official sentence date is
set for August 21st
[Music]